this is a billion dollars we think and
that billion dollars belongs to r.j.
Rappaport and he's considered the king
of cash your fake cash okay
king of fake cash my name is rich r.j.
Rappaport and I'm the president of RJR
props just a few years ago actually it
was nine years ago
oh sorry nine years ago RJ R props was
born it's a full-service prop house but
its specialty is cash think cash and
there's only a few people who can
legally make it an RJ is one of them we
work with 50 cent Kendrick Lamar Lil
Wayne Fat Joe Young Dolph and that's
just to name a few
RJ's prop money has been used in over
175 feature films television shows and
music videos and he devoted three full
years to perfecting that crisp green
paper we call money prop money and we
went down a long path and working with
the Secret Service and learning all the
laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules they could wind
up in big trouble there was a rash of
arrests people were just literally
jailed because they were using prop
money that looked too real and I said to
myself I'm not gonna touch this unless I
know I'm doing it legally alongside The
Secret Service
RJ created two different styles of prop
money one that is printed on both sides
and is perfect for that classic bank
robbery scene
the other kind is so close to the real
deal it can only be printed on one side
otherwise it could end up in circulation
it's designed for the classic money shot
aka the close-up it's a tough business
we all work hard in it and prop money
especially it's not easy yeah sounds
like it thanks RJ for keeping fake money
real
[Music]